hola siempre tengo miedos escalones
porque siempre me tropiezo pero lo logré
bueno muchísimas gracias por esa
increíble presentación
hoy les voy a presentar un tema bien
interesante que se llama instagram
ability y su poder para cambiar el
turismo mundial
esto yo es una de las pocas fotos que
tengo de mí y es mi nueva foto de
tinelli de bombón porque es la única en
la que salgo bien es bueno
contín kreator travel y roller que es
como me describo yo
algunos de ustedes quizás tampoco sabrán
que hago ni a qué me dedico hago
contenido y estas son algunas de las
marcas para las que he trabajado como
verán la mayoría son marcas de viajes
como vizitiu son o no más republic
también soy runner soy maratonista
aunque me ven así medio xavi y gordito
éste también corro llevo seis maratones
el próximo mes corro parís y
corrí tres veces desde la ciudad de
méxico entonces valen como 10
estos presos vendrán aquí y también por
ejemplo en la corona porque aparte de
viajar y correr también me gusta empinar
la bien paz
bueno el tema más importante dentro de
instagram y de lo que hago yo es el
storytelling
instagram dentro del tema de los viajes
realmente se ha vuelto una fuente de
inspiración pero últimamente se ha
consolidado como una guía de viajes la
gente ahora decide sus decir sus
destinos turísticos o sus vacaciones
dependiendo de qué tan bonito es el
lugar y que tantas fotos van a poder
tomar en ese lugar
al principio instagram era más estaba
más en el cuadrante de la fantasía y de
la aspiración veíamos ya saben a este o
esta fashion blogger en el yate en el
atardecer perfecto tomándose la copa de
champaña más cara y es como wow pues qué
padre algún día me gustaría ser así pero
es inalcanzable no todos podemos irnos
ni tenemos el cuerpo ni tenemos las
oportunidades de hacer eso pero gracias
a la evolución del content marketing de
la importancia del contenido más que del
número de followers ahora instagram está
mucho más basado en algo que te inspires
pero sobre todo algo que sea real algo
que realmente si podemos alcanzar
porque instagram nos gusta tanto porque
tiene muchas ventajas la verdad es que
ha desfalcado a muchas otras redes
sociales como facebook o twitter ahorita
como que agarro nuevo furor porque cada
vez somos más haters y twitter es como
el lugar donde nos desahogamos de todo
pero bueno instagram permite ser actual
por ejemplo el día que fue el eclipse el
eclipse lunar todos los que subieron
fotos ese día estaban como al momento e
inclusive todos los que subieron fotos
de la luna les fue súper bien inmediatez
tuve la oportunidad de irme con corona
al mundial fue una cosa increíble porque
me avisaron una semana antes ya tiene
otros planes de jamás me había imaginado
ir a un mundial y fue entonces instagram
lo que te permite es antes del partido
tomar una foto editarla rapidísimo y
subirla el engagement porque pongo esta
foto porque si suben una foto de un
perrito un gatito les tiene asegurado
muchísimos likes y muchísimos
comentarios esta no es una frivolidad es
un proyecto que hice la adopción de
perritos entonces tú también les fue muy
bien
porque nos gusta instagram porque
también podemos crear los lugares a los
que vamos entonces tuvimos una foto está
por ejemplo en la medina de fez en
marruecos
instagram te permite encontrar todos los
lugares con esa ubicación
también el uso de hashtags este por
ejemplo es uno que me cree yo con otros
cinco amigos instagram eros que se llama
red ton kingdom y fue un viaje que
hicimos a eeuu hay más de 300 fotos en
este hashtag y es un viaje de 55 estados
de eeuu en diferentes parques nacionales
si quieren luego le echan un ojo o hay
hashtags ya hechos por otras marcas por
ejemplo si yo el citi es un hashtag que
utiliza una de las principales la
principal oficina de promoción turística
de nueva york y si ustedes suben una
foto utilizando este hashtag es muy
probable que ellos la agarren y la suban
a su cuenta
y finalmente instagram nos gusta pues
porque lo amamos llamamos compartir
cosas ahí están dos amigos damos de un
best action en la villa olímpica en
londres y pues nada me parece un momento
muy bonito ahora pasamos al término
importante esta plática la instagram
ability cuántas veces no hemos dicho hay
es que este lugar es bien instagram e
hable o ahí es que esté el este hotel
está bien padre es bien instagram e able
instagram ability básicamente es el
concepto
de algo que tiene un potencial visual
muy fuerte algo que es muy bonito y
entonces le podemos tomar una foto lo
que les decía antes el 40 por ciento de
los millennials actualmente deciden su
destino para vacacionar no porque
también se la van a pasar ni con quién
van a ir si no lo eligen porque tanto
potencial fotografiable tec
entonces la instagram ability junta el
amor por los viajes el amor por la
fotografía pero obviamente estas dos no
sirven si no lo podemos compartir y
presumirle a nuestros amigos donde
estamos obviamente
a pesar de lo que ustedes pudieran creer
los lugares más instagram ea-2 del 2017
disneyland tiene un fuerte dominio sobre
muchos lugares más impresionantes en
primer lugar está disneyland de eeuu y
esto que nos da a entender que ya no
están ganando los lugares que realmente
son bonitos por ejemplo los lugares
naturales ahora están ganando los
lugares hechos artificialmente para que
uno le den ganas de tomarse fotos ahí
los países más visitados del 2018
francia españa eeuu méxico está en el
lugar 6 qué maravilla es una foto en
mladá por cierto todas las fotos que
están ahí son mías
- la anterior la de disneyland es de
alan por el mundo porque yo no he oído
tristemente a disneyland pero sí ya sé
aunque preferiría ir al mundo de harry
potter larga los países más esta gran
hables del 2019 esta fue una
investigación que se hizo a través de
encuestas a través de hashtags y
monitoreo digital y resulta que el país
más instagram me hable de este año es
australia méxico cae hasta la posición
23 no culpen a amlo por favor porque
seguramente verdad la transformación de
cuarta y así pero no es culpa de él y
hay lugares bien interesantes por
ejemplo eeuu sigue en octavo lo cual
quiere decir que que lo está haciendo
muy bien
algunos ejemplos de lugares instagram me
hablés este fue uno de los lugares más
fotografiados el año pasado algunos de
ustedes ya habían visto esta imagen es
un puente se llama el golden bridge que
están causando no sé vietnamita entonces
no me critiquen mi pronunciación
este puente es tan bonito y tan visual
que se vuelve el fenómeno instagram
instagram del 2018
mount rondón es el segundo punto más y
está graneado más fotografiado en
instagram de canadá después de las
cataratas del niágara yo no lo sabía y
lo acabo de descubrir
tuve el placer de irme con alan por el
mundo a república dominicana en
diciembre del 2018 y visitamos la
montaña redonda la montaña redonda es un
cerro bastante feo vive en el cerro pero
tiene unas vistas increíbles y
maravillosas entonces a alguien se le
ocurrió poner unos columpios entonces tú
vas e inclusive le puedes pagar a
alguien para que te empuje y entonces te
empuja y alguien más te toma la foto
entonces el hecho de poderse tomar una
foto en un fin en un columpio infiniti
y ha hecho que este lugar se ha vuelto
más visitado que puntacana que es el
lugar más famoso de república dominicana
es una cosa tan tonta como poner un
columpio en el que te puedes tomar una
foto increíble ha desbancado a otros
sitios turísticos más importantes de ese
país bueno de ciudad de méxico quizá
algo de lo que más me gusta es bellas
artes entonces por eso lo quise incluir
que es un monumento o hay cosas un poco
más banales o menos como monumentales
pero que también son muy instagram
hables por ejemplo este es el puentecito
peatonal que te lleva al museo
universitario de arte contemporáneo y yo
siempre que voy al museo siempre me
tengo que tomar una foto en este puente
aquí hay un capítulo que yo le llamo el
arte en los tiempos de instagram y quise
incluirlo porque ahora no sé si se han
dado cuenta si les gustará los museos
que han dejado la curaduría de arte muy
importante a nivel mundial por favorecer
exposiciones e instalaciones muy grandes
en las que la gente quiere ir a tomarse
fotos
por ejemplo la araña la araña está maman
que pusieron en bellas artes afuera todo
mundo se va a tomar fotos con ella la
instalación de los puentes eso se llama
ponte galei anti que lo hicieron el lago
di zeo en italia hace un par de años se
volvió la sensación todo el mundo visitó
este lugar en italia no se acuerdan de
el hitazo de yayoi kusama hace unos años
nadie conocía yayoi kusama está nadie
bueno la mayor yo creo que el 80% de los
que fueron a tomarse la foto al infinity
room no tenían ni idea de quién era
yayoi kusama pero se fueron a tomar su
foto o este anís kapur
en el mar les incluir los museos más y
hasta graneados de 2017 el look está en
primer lugar y justamente estos museos
también han caído no en el error sino yo
creo que es algo importante y algo
bonito que han estado haciendo porque
mucha gente que antes no acudía a los
museos ahora lo está haciendo no importa
si es para tomarse la foto pero han
acercado la cultura y el arte a un
público que antes no existía
el poder de instagram ha llegado al
punto tan grande que easyjet la compañía
aérea creó una app que tú le tomas un
screenshot a una foto de instagram que
les gusta de algún destino turístico la
meten a esta app la reconoce el destino
turístico y les ofrece vuelos a ese
lugar
no solo los países o las ciudades se han
dado cuenta de este poder de instagram
sino inclusive en los hoteles ahora
muchos hoteles se han dedicado a hacer
muy instagram eav les cambian su lobby
ponen un columpio y ponen cosas muy
interesantes a nivel visual dentro de su
infraestructura para que la gente vaya
diga es que me quiero tomar una foto
dentro de ese hotel
los hoteles más está graneados de 2017
en primer lugar está el marina bay y el
ave la única razón por la que este hotel
está en primer lugar es por esta piscina
la infinity pool que tiene en su último
piso lo cual está increíble y mucha
gente sólo va a tomarse la foto de hecho
puedes pagar sólo por la alberca y
básicamente estás pagando solo por la
foto
y hemos llegado el punto de que algunos
hoteles ya a nivel mundial ofrecen el
servicio de photo butler entonces tú
llegas al hotel y le dices es que quiero
alguien que me acompañe a los puntos más
visitados de la ciudad a tomarme fotos y
algunos hoteles ofrecen este servicio si
me quieren contratar a este man del
mundo a direct y con mucho gusto los
acompañan
dado el poder de instagram para atraer
turistas a ciertos lugares también ha
surgido una contracorriente que es no yo
tag algunos destinos como islandia
ya se han visto desbordados de turismo
antes islandia hace diez años recibía
200.000 turistas el año pasado recibió
más de 3 millones entonces son lugares
muy naturales y muy bonitos pero debido
a que se han vuelto muy populares por
ejemplo en instagram cada vez reciben
muchísimo turismo y ha habido países que
han tenido que tomar medidas drásticas
por ejemplo la playa de la película la
playa de leonardo dicaprio que está en
tailandia se vio obligado a cerrar a
miami pero lo bonito de eso es que la
cerraron y después de unos meses
descubrieron que los tiburones que ya
nos acercaban a las costas volvieron
entonces también se han visto resultados
muy bonitos a nivel ambiental
es por eso por ejemplo este ejemplo que
les acabo de decir que yo dentro de mis
viajes ahora los llamamos frívolos pero
no obviamente son viajes padres que hago
para dar a conocer lugares porque eso me
dedico he empezado a hacer viajes con
causa consisten en viajar ir a lugares
pero tener un impacto ambiental y social
a las comunidades a las que visitamos
entonces llevan una semana a la playa
obviamente para tomarse cócteles a la
playa a nadar a salir de noche por
ejemplo dedicar un solo día a recoger
basura de la playa ya le están haciendo
un bien muy muy importante es el lugar
entonces yo ya estoy trabajando con una
organización que se llama nueva
república y estoy tratando de promover a
través de instagram los viajes con causa
ahora muchas marcas desde hace unos años
se dieron cuenta del gran poder que
tiene instagram para promover destinos
turísticos y dijeron bueno por qué no
comenzamos a invitar influencers a los
viajes a mí la verdad es que nunca me ha
gustado la palabra influencia porque me
parece muy presunto así pero bueno es la
palabra que se utiliza en influenciar
marketing porque los influencers han
tenido tanto éxito en promover lugares a
través de la plataforma pues porque
inspiran confianza no yo por eso escogí
a alan alan se me hace el mejor y más
importante influencer de viajes que hay
en bueno en habla hispana porque porque
alan inspira como conocen hablan por el
mundo
estas fotos de 207 mil likes y no es una
foto como que sería un monumento
increíble o algo así lo que me gustó de
esta foto es que se ve tan natural el
segundo punto
él se fue se fue y se instaló en bagan
en birmania y estuvo viviendo hay un mes
completo entonces aprendió a convivir
con la comunidad y justamente esta foto
expresa todo eso entonces alan es
confiable entonces te va decir visitaba
gana es seguro es bonito y todo y tú le
vas a creer
las fotos son naturales su contenido es
orgánico tiene mucho alcance
y su contenido es muy bueno los invito a
los que no lo conozcan a ver su canal de
youtube o sus fotos en instagram que me
parecen maravillosas y ha sido una de
las mayores inspiraciones para mí
guau
en esta foto también salí bien porque
nada se me ve la mitad de la cara
tips de foto para viaje con esto quiero
acabar mucha gente bueno mucha gente
ya aparezco este blogger de vista hay
mucha gente me ha preguntado qué crema
uso y algunas personas me han preguntado
sobre algunos tips de fotografía cuando
viajo entonces quise poner 5 que a mí se
me hacen como los que más utilizo yo al
momento de tomar fotos no tienen que ser
profesionales de hecho yo este artículo
lo hice basado en fotografía móvil
entonces yo creo que todo el mundo tiene
un smartphone y tiene apps para editar
entonces
minimalismo a qué me refiero con esto a
mí siempre me ha parecido mucho más
importante el lugar con las personas que
habitan en ese lugar más que yo viajando
hasta tomándome la selphy con la torre
eiffel a mí eso me parece un poco más
banal entonces a mí siempre me gusta
demostrar el panorama entero aquí vemos
unas palmeras en república dominicana y
siempre me ha gustado incluir como una
personita chiquitita porque siento que
el factor humano es muy importante y a
la gente le gusta ver personas en las
fotos entonces primer tip es minimalismo
coloquen una persona chiquitito y denle
importancia al escenario
simetría esto se lo debo a mi primo en
just a fox que en realidad fue el que
metió al mundo de instagram y es un
obsesionado con las cosas simétricas
entonces siempre busco poner al
individuo en medio de la foto ejes
cuadrantes y estoy obsesionado con los
reflejos y este es un tip extra que les
voy a dar cuando tomen fotos de charcos
o de superficies de agua con su celular
pónganlo al revés para que el lente
quede lo más cerca del agua y capturen
un poco más del reflejo parece una
tontería yo no lo sabía pero si funciona
de la neta es que si funciona
movimiento en lugar de tomar a la
persona quieta usen una persona saltando
corriendo eso les va a dar dinamismo
dentro de la foto
los atardeceres los amaneceres son mis
momentos preferidos del día juegan un
poco con la luz la verdad es que la
tecnología de los nuevos smartphones te
permiten más o menos monitorear la luz y
tomar una buena foto entonces es
cuestión de andar le picoteando a la
pantalla hasta que les agarre lo que
quieren y finalmente jugar jueguen un
poco con luces y sombras es una foto que
tome en un museo bien bonito de aquí de
la ciudad de mexico que ahorita no me
acuerdo cómo se llama y que osó esto va
a quedar inmortalizado por eso tomo
fotos porque tengo muy mala memoria pero
necesitaría ver dónde es todos juegan un
poco con las luces y con las sombras les
da un efecto muy divertido
y pues nada mi consejo sigamos viajando
tomando fotos y compartiendo
experiencias
en instagram muchas gracias
igual creo que no lo iba a lograr este
cronómetro pone muy nervioso
pues bueno ya esté que funciona pues el
protocolo me voy
gracias gracias por su atención
[Aplausos]